you
the world's changing boys time we change
to the vulture is way by Michael Keaton
and the vulture is planning on stealing
the weapons have been left behind from
any Avengers disaster we're going to
take everything they've got
I Thailand a really interesting approach
to what you all want to call a villain
you don't understand how the world works
the rich and the powerful like stark
they don't care by us the vulture does
corrupt things or despite what you see
is corruption a few things themselves
and they all have theirs where's mine
he and his men basically work with that
hand
she doesn't have any inherent
superpowers she starts the utilize
technology to hover here
these lessons are crazy dangerous
Michael Keaney he has a very intense
malevolence to him which is really
really scary don't mess with that
because every what do you want superhero
movie is only as good as devil
1pp scene he come with the character he
really did nail it ha
you